il redoutait l'audience à la cour
d'appel de dijon le voilà soulagés mais
l'avocat ça s'est bien passé on s'est
donc fait ils sont très gentils je suis
pas allé jusqu'au bout maintenant les
années tourne non j'aurais bien que
possible
je suis très content 23 ans que michel
bluzet se bat pour rétablir la vérité
sur la mort de sa fille virginie
assassiné en 1997 la justice envisageait
de classer le dossier comme ce fut le
cas en 2002 mais le parquet général a
finalement changé de position favorables
à la poursuite des investigations
deux pistes sont alors privilégiée par
la défense la première mène à michel
fourniret
l' enquête permettrait de comparer l'adn
de la victime à se retrouver chez le
tueur en série qui a vécu dans l'yonne
l'autre piste c'est celle de pascal
jardin condamné pour l'assassinât de
christelle blétry en 1996 pour l'avocat
de michel bluzet les similitudes avec le
meurtre de sa fille sont troublantes
la mort de virginie bluzet intervient
quelques semaines après celle de
christelle blétry
donc on a une unité de temps unité de
lieu
qui fait qu' il est logique qu'on
s'intéresse au parcours de pascal jardin
et c'est ce que nous avons monté les
proches de virginie bluzet devront
encore attendre jusqu'au 16 décembre
prochain date à laquelle la cour d'appel
rendra sa décision ce n'est qu'après que
les investigations pourront reprendre